here's my advice okay if you just really
believe in yourself
I know you're doing your best and you're
proud of the way you're living then one
day you might wind up on a pink backdrop
just like playing with the [ __ ] ton of
puppies
what's better motivation than that
[Laughter]
hi I'm Amy Schumer and I'm answering fan
questions while playing with puppies
okay guys are you ready have you ever
had an embarrassing workout story an
incident happened to you like Renee and
I feel pretty well this dog just like
kind of peed on me an embarrassing
workout experience yeah I've had a lot
oh one time when I was working out and
going for a walk in Austin I [ __ ] myself
you guys know what that's like oh he was
even wanted he just wants love okay
sorry questions okay Renee go as a
tramatic online group date experience
have you had a bad online dating
experience I was online dating for like
truly 24 hours and it was dramatic
enough that I wanted to get out of there
but then I've also had a but you know I
also met a guy I had like a nice couple
years relationship with from online so
I've got no online hate but you kind of
start to feel really bad about yourself
you know it's like you kind of get
judged like this is how much you're
worth yeah and it makes you feel bad
about yourself
it's such a meat market but I don't know
a lot of people fell in love on there
like we just fell in love but I think
we've got these dogs online
I like that there's wet footprints and
like we know it it's from I'm stranded
on the desert island which of these
people that I've worked with before do I
want with you Goldie Hawn LeBron James
Jennifer Lawrence or John Cena Goldie
Hawn hands down Goldie is you want to be
stuck anywhere with her because Jennifer
would eat me you know she'd be like this
is fun we'll have fun and then she'd
start looking at me like I was a chicken
really fast but Goldie would you know we
Dudley's party for a little while first
okay what makes you feel pretty puppies
um I feel pretty oh that's actually
thank you thank you sir yeah be around
your friends that I know it sounds corny
but seriously when you're just like with
your friends and you're laughing and you
just feel really like yourself and
authentic and yeah but also when someone
has sex with you it's pretty you're like
okay I must have lived well enough that
I you wanted have sex with me so that's
a compliment
how will married life change your
stand-up material sir um I don't know I
just started doing it I mean it's
nobody's ever gonna text me you up again
so I'll just have to start just you know
talking about ma'am ma'am ma'am ma'am
Siobhan Qi ma'am oh I can't stay mad at
you
uh I don't know I just need to get a lot
of dogs you're a little biter
okay Jennifer Lawrence recently said you
gave her some tough love after a breakup
she ever given you similar advice well I
didn't give her advice I just sent her
flowers saying that I was sorry that she
was gonna die alone and I stand by that
I love Jennifer she's one of my best
friends and you know she's beautiful on
camera and she's she's an incredible
actress but in a person when you're when
Jennifer's up close she it all melts
away and she's very hideous Jen is um
yeah I knew I could mess with Jen about
her breakup she'll she'll bounce back
quick what what if that was an important
question what if this happened with the
the Constitution what's the craziest
rumor you've ever heard about yourself
um I read a rumor once that I had I
don't even want to say this but it was
that I'd gone to jail for punching
someone in the face at the Oscars and
I've never gone to the Oscars but yeah
it was written as fact Congrats on your
marriage how and when did you know your
husband was the one when he introduced
himself as a chef you worked with
Michelle Williams and busy and I feel
pretty where you make Dawson's Creek fan
growing up yes of course I have a
beating heart so of course I like
Dawson's Creek what are you doing
cuz you just got very still all of a
sudden and I'm definitely concerned
about that what about you
look at this little face are you so cute
Oh what celebrity makes you laugh the
most
[Music]
what celebrity makes me laugh the most
the the funniest you know your teeth are
no joke like we got to be real Dave
Attell makes me laugh unless the
comedian and he's in the movie truly
biting glass truly you hear a little
vampire you're like Robert Pattinson
look at this I'm gonna name you Robert
Pattinson and you're Kristen Stewart and
you're Anna Kendrick and you're Taylor
something
[Music]
Momsen all these puppies are available
for adoption at North Shore Animal
League America except for this one
you're comin with me are you
[Music]